et un et deux et trois après michel
rocard après benoît hamon c'est au tour
de valérie pécresse d'être victime de ce
qu'on pourrait appeler la malédiction
des yvelines une malédiction qui fait
que les candidats originaires aux
représentants de ce département non
seulement ne parviennent pas à se hisser
au premier rang des présidentiables mais
qu'ils abandonnent aussi dans ce combat
une part de leur ambition politique
comme si leurs candidatures aux
présidentielles avait précipité leur
chute souvenez vous de michel rocard
nous sommes en octobre 1981 michel
rocard qui représente la deuxième gauche
et le plus populaire des socialistes
loin devant françois mitterrand comme
valéry giscard d'estaing s'est en plus
tôt michel rocard a choisi sa mairie
celle de conflans sainte honorine pour y
annoncer sa candidature
ce sera un flop sur la forme michel
rocard ne regarde pas la bonne caméra
son style et ampoulé et sur le fond
hésitant à s'adresser soit aux français
soit aux militants socialistes
il finit par ne pas choisir et même par
est fermé ce qui est un comble pour
quelqu'un qui se présente contre lui
qu'il faut que les militants se
rassemble derrière leur premier
secrétaire alias françois mitterrand
mitterrand ne s'y trompera pas il sait
qu'en commettant ce faux pas son
concurrent lui a permis de se relancer
dans la course et le 6 novembre
il annonce sa candidature
c'en est fini des espoirs de michel
rocard janvier 2017 benoît hamon celui
qu'on n'attendait pas à pareille fête
devient le candidat de la gauche
socialiste il a devancé ségolène royal
arnaud montebourg et battu à plate
couture l'ancien premier ministre manuel
valls au deuxième tour des primaires et
nos 58 % des voix des militants les
sondages le donnent à 18% trois points
devant jean-luc mélenchon et yannick
jadot candidat des verts se retire en sa
faveur mais l'état de grâce dure peu de
temps lâché par la machine socialiste
finalement assez solitaire et se
repliant sur son plan benoît hamon se
montre incapable de rassembler la gauche
socialiste et écologiste se renfermement
sur soi va provoquer la chute de benoît
hamon des électeurs de gauche s'éloigner
plus radicaux se tourner vers jean luc
mélenchon les plus modernistes
rejoignent emmanuel macron et benoît
hamon se retrouvent dans les sondages au
dessous de la barre fatidique des 10% la
glissade commence elle ne s'arrêtera pas
avec à peine plus de 6% des voix benoît
hamon conduire à la gauche socialiste
verso pire échec électoral depuis le
congrès d'epinay ironie de l'histoire ce
score pour lamentable qu'il soit aurait
sans doute fait rêver une anne hidalgo
qui n'a même pas atteint les 2% des
suffrages le 2 décembre 2021 le résultat
du premier tour des primaires internes à
allaire réserve une grosse surprise tout
le monde attendait xavier bertrand et
c'est le très droitiste eric ciotti qui
arrive en tête pour la deuxième place
valérie pécresse coiffe ses concurrents
dont bertrand et barnier et tous se
rallier à la présidente de l'île de
france deux jours plus tard la voici
candidate de la droite républicaine
les premières enquêtes puis sont très
favorables elle apparaît comme la seule
candidate qui puisse faire chuter
emmanuel macron et puis l'idée d'une
femme à l'elysée enfin fait son chemin
reste un problème de fond valérie
pécresse qui a débuté à ses côtés
lorsqu'il était président de la
république se dit chiraquienne or
comment concilier ce chiraquisme
c'est-à-dire ce radicalisme bon teint
qui respire la corrèze et le bon sens et
des thèses ultra droitière défendue par
le sparadrap ciotti qui colle à valérie
pécresse comme la moule s'accroche au
rocher des visites voire impossible si
elle penche trop du côté de l'europe et
du modernisme valérie pécresse est
accusé de trahir ses militants si elle
reprend à son compte l'image du karcher
ou la thèse du grand remplacement elle y
perd sa sincérité c'est peut-être cette
difficulté à être elle-même qui
caractérise l'échec de sa campagne tout
s'est passé comme si on l'avait
contrainte à faire ce qu'elle n'aimait
pas ou pire ce qu'elle ne savait pas
faire comme ce meeting tragique de la
porte de versailles mal filmé mal mise
en scène qui sonna le début de la fin en
ne parvenant même pas à la barre des 5
morceaux valérie pécresse a plongé le
parti de la droite républicaine dans le
coma politique et en écoutant son
discours sincère de dimanche soir dans
lequel elle a appelé à voter emmanuel
macron certains regretteront peut-être
qu'elle n'ait pas été elle-même plus tôt